we were filming in Atlanta right now
it's going very well it's going very
well and every day there are shots there
are images that are pairing of
characters you've never seen before on
screen that again I'm very lucky to do
what I do I'm very thankful to do what I
do and I do it because I think out for
these everybody is Charlie we got to
talk about mutants inside the MCU
everybody wondering about how they're
gonna cross the x-men characters over
with all the Marvel MCU characters with
a really cool thing is there are
actually three ways that Marvel has
secretly already introduced mutants into
the MCU without really coming out and
saying it because they can't use the
term mutant legally because of copyright
that Fox holds right now which will
obviously go away next year because
Disney will get all the rights to that
so they have to find interesting ways of
explaining these powers without actually
calling them mutants but that's what
they are that's gonna play out during
Avengers 4 and continue through Avengers
5 in the next couple of Avengers movies
as they start to populate the MCU with
all these x-men characters there's a new
round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
Marvel related comment on the video uh
name a new winner at the end of this the
first way that Marvel secretly already
introduced the x-men and mutants into
the MCU is through scarlet which I've
talked a little bit about this before
but it's only come to light recently how
they did it even though they did it a
while ago mercifully it's not that
complicated so in order for this to work
we have to explain the difference
between a mutant and someone who has
biologically based powers so a
spider-man the Hulk Captain America
Black Panthers they all have powers that
are biological in nature but they only
got those powers later in life they were
born like normal people the difference
with mutants is is that they're born
with the X gene that gives them that
potential and that something has to
unlock the X gene or activate it later
in life what Marvel did to confirm
Scarlet Witch mutant in the MCU is that
they released a visual dictionary for
the first ten years of Marvel Studios
the book itself is canon and what they
explained is is that the mine stone
merely unlocked latent ability within
Scarlet Witch isn't it activated her X
gene but obviously because of copyright
reasons they can't use the term mutant
yet and they wrote the book last year so
they just had to say unlocking latent
ability in that sort of code for MCU
mutant the second way that they secretly
introduced all these mutant characters
is through the quantum realm quantum
energy in the multiverse via Janet Van
Dyne is convenient explainer
I thought I was gone but that energy
from your hands how did you do that I'm
not the same woman I was 30 years ago
Henry this place it changes you an
adaptation is part of it but some of it
is evolution so this is a bit of a
mystery box situation they have not
fully explained what happened to her her
down there only that she is a
quote-unquote changed person
like she's fundamentally altered in a
way that say like Captain America or
black panther were not recently Michael
Douglas was also saying that he feels
like the quantum realm is the future of
the MCU in terms of storytelling so when
you say it changes people and it's this
mystery power source that is the next
frontier
according to Sonny birch really wants to
sell it for billions and billions of
dollars to mysterious villains who we
haven't heard about in the MCU yet just
the way they hyped it up during ant-man
in the wasp but it seems like it's
almost or as powerful as any of the
power that you would find within the
Infinity stones given the plot twist
that it's the key to the multiverse
there are just many ways to explain on a
fundamental level how there are
different realities where mutants have
been a thing for a long time but maybe
not necessarily in our reality
Avengers traveling through the quantum
realm ant-man and the wasp characters
messing with things that they probably
shouldn't mess with could all lead to
different aspects of realities bleeding
into each other explaining how
characters could have been around this
whole time without us really noticing
them the third way that Marvel already
secretly introduced the idea of mutants
into the MCU is through the Eternals
franchise which they haven't started
filming yet so that's kind of something
that's coming up but the whole idea with
the e Turtles is that the Celestials on
the orders of eternity we're trying to
garden the universe giving rise to
experimentations and certain kinds of
life them creating the Eternals on
planet earth provides a biological basis
for the x-gene
the way the comics have explained it
more recently is is that the celestial
energy that's left over from what they
did with the Eternals seeped into
Earth's crust that leftover celestial
energy changed the course of
human evolution giving rise to the X
gene in the human genome so a lot of
people wonder like where did the X gene
come from now within the Marvel Universe
that came from celestial experimentation
on planet earth millions of years ago so
there's also other cool storylines
involving the Celestials that they'll
get into with the Eternals franchise
about like what happens when the
celestial host returns to Planet Earth
to destroy their experiment you don't
need to worry about too much of that now
because we'll find out about the
Eternals franchise once Kevin Feige
starts revealing all of their phase 4
plans but for now it just provides a
basis for how x-men characters can exist
in the MCU people who are born with the
X gene in the latent ability that may
not have been activated yet but I know a
lot of you just want to know what's
gonna happen with Professor X magneto
Wolverine Reed Richards all the other
core x-men and Fantastic Four characters
how is Marvel gonna explain them
existing in the MCU because the way the
CEO of Disney has been talking about
he's been saying they're bringing those
characters into the MCU they might leave
Deadpool off by himself but he also did
tease you know maybe Deadpool will show
up with the Avengers in a movie at some
point but in order for everything to
make sense you do have to consider the
Canon that they've already set up that's
what you're seeing so much of the
universe in the MCU the actual physical
universe being changed by the snapping
in what's happening during Avengers 4 so
like right now present-day
Scarlet Witch and the Infinity stones is
a template you introduce one character
from that group of Fox Marvel characters
he sort of pioneers the exploration of
all the other big ones Reed Richards and
Professor X are probably better places
to start than other characters because
Professor X can be one of those powerful
mutants like Scarlet Witch that had a
latent ability that manifested because
he was so powerful and he just chose to
hide it when he was young and because of
all the stuff that happened during civil
war with Scarlet Witch in how people
fear her as a mutant like people fear
x-men in all the x-men movies but
somehow everybody on planet Earth loves
the Avengers so you kind of have to
explain how society hates mutants but
loved superheroes so you can still do
that through what happened to Scarlet
Witch during civil war there are a
couple of x-men characters that you kind
of have to introduce together in
for their group to make sense like
Professor X and Magneto had to be
relatively close to the same age what
you do now is as you say Scarlet Witch
is the first publicly outed mutant but
Professor X he's been around this whole
time but his ability has allowed him to
hide from view so that's how the
Avengers haven't picked up on him yet
because of all the stuff they're doing
with Dark Phoenix as being sort of a
swan song for the Fox Marvel movies I do
think that there's going to be
widespread rebooting of a lot of
characters you could try to bring McEvoy
and Fassbender in but I think it would
be easier to reboot those characters in
the MCU and then if you really want to
do it way down the road like many many
years in the future you could do a
secret war style movie where many
universes collided with each other so
you do get to see many different
versions of the characters and that can
be their way of having the same type of
fun that they had with x-men Days of
Future past where you have different
versions of the characters interacting
with each other but I think the beauty
and all this just remember is as they've
already introduced mutants in the MCU
they just haven't called them that yet I
think the real question is is who will
be playing those characters so let me
know in the comments do you want to meet
Reed Richards first or do you want to
meet Professor X first because you could
use either one of those characters to
introduce all of the others there's a
bunch of stuff coming up so I'll post
video updates and that top pin comment
on the video here
congratulations me Mada to corbata
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here to learn
why Netflix cancelled iron fist and Luke
Cage and click here to learn about the
big Marvel phase 4 movie changes that
they just announced
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]